When we are watching movies it is easy to
spot mistakes when you are not enjoying the
film but when the film is enjoyable it’s
much harder to spot.
That’s because we are so engrossed into
the story we aren’t paying attention to
mistakes but that’s why we are here.
To spot out these fun mistakes so you don’t
have to and can continue enjoying these blockbuster
films.
Let us know when we spot one from your favorite
film by liking or commenting on our videos
and don’t forget to subscribe to Screen
Rant and join our notification squad so you
can be the first to know about our newest
videos.
Here is Screen Rant’s list of ten Mistakes
In Popular Movies That Were Caught Too Late.
Captain America: Civil War
When the trailer for Captain America: Civil
War came out everyone went crazy over the
inclusion of cast member Tom Holland as Spider-Man.
The shot that kept being played over and over
again is when Spidey shoots a web onto Captain
America’s shield and snatches it.
Take a look at all that webbing he needed
to use to take the shield and then take a
look at the clean shield when he lands.
Maybe Captain America just polished his shield
and that’s why the webbing came off.
It’s important to keep your equipment clean.
Suicide Squad
We’ll be honest with you, catching Harley
Quinn mistakes are easy not because she makes
a lot of them but because we can’t take
our eyes off her.
Despite her being a wacko, she does do some
odd things in the movie though.
When they are picking out weapons she picks
up a mallet, which is a nod to her comic book
character but then later on she uses a bat
as her weapon of choice.
And when she jumps in an elevator to beat
the other squad members to the top, why are
they up there waiting for her?
What was the point of having her use the elevator?
Here’s a trivia question for you, what were
the Suicide Squad originally named in the
comic books?
The answer will be at the end of our video.
The Empire Strikes Back
One of the greatest movie lines of all time
is Han Solo’s response to Princess Leia
when she tells him that she loves him.
It’s also something you shouldn’t say
to your girlfriend if she ever says she loves
you.
From the shots of Solo with Leia you can see
he has no jacket on but then when they cut
to his famous line he has a jacket.
Wait a second, you can’t see it?
That’s because George Lucas lightened the
jacket for the re-release but you can see
that it’s shiny like leather and we also
have these stills from the original release
to show you.
Next Lucas will change who shot first.
Finding Dory
When Hank and Dory make their way through
the aquarium in a stroller, we learn that
not only does Hank make an ugly baby but there
are a few goof ups with all the excitement.
When the little girl spills the popcorn, look
at popcorn cup fly out of frame but then in
the next shot it didn’t fall that far away
from the popcorn.
But that isn’t the biggest oops in this
scene, let’s go back and look at her shirt
of the little girl when she was hit, then
take a look at it after she was hit.
Looks like she made a quick costume change.
Batman V Superman: Dawn of Justice
Seeing two of DC’s greatest characters fight
it out in Batman V Superman: Dawn of Justice
was awesome to see on the big screen.
These legends colliding than working side
by side were a dream to comic book fans of
every age.
When Batman gains the upper hand on Superman,
Superman’s hair is out of place.
A great way to show Superman loosing his powers
but when Superman fights Doomsday his hair
is perfectly combed again.
Maybe he stopped to add some gel to his hair
before saving the world.
He has to keep impressing Lois Lane, you know.
Inside Out
Here are a few contradictions in the movie
Inside Out and the way Riley’s memory works,
take a look at her running around the house
as a child.
It is her point of view but then when they
show other memories of Riley’s, like her
ice skating they are not in her point of view.
Also, take a look at the way she dreams, when
she loses her teeth they fall down crossing
her eyes.
In reality her mouth is below her eyes so
how would she see them?
Maybe in Riley’s dreams her mouth is on
her forehead and that’s how the teeth were
able to fall past her eyes.
Do you know plays the voice of Joy in Inside
Out, Sarah Silverman, Amy Poehler or Will
Ferrell?
Stick around to the end for the answer.
Jurassic Park
Sometimes a filmmaker will intentionally make
a mistake because it is for the benefit of
the story and Steven Spielberg did not shy
away from this in his 1993 blockbuster, Jurassic
Park.
When a goat waits to be T-Rex’s dinner he
is on a flat piece of land and on top of that
the T-Rex walks through that same flat land
to attack the jeeps and a guy using the bathroom.
Then when the T-Rex knocks the jeep off the
road it falls down a cliff.
Where did that cliff come from?
We’re too caught up in Spielberg’s great
storytelling to even notice.
Ant-Man
This is a little mistake from a movie about
the littlest superhero out there.
When we learn how the original Wasp dies through
a back flash scene we see her land on a nuclear
missile with her husband.
Since this is a Russian missile why are the
letters in English and not in the Cyrillic
alphabet.
The Cyrillic alphabet has been the written
language of Russia since the 9th century and
is still used today.
Maybe the missile was stolen from the Americans
by the Russians and they were using our own
weapons against us.
Yes, we’ll go with that and say this wasn’t
a mistake.
Deadpool
As Deadpool is driven to his destination by
Dopinder the Taxi Driver the two men exchange
some of the best one-liners from the film.
During their exchange Deadpool loads his twelve
bullets into one clip and loads it into his
gun.
Then when we see him strategically using his
twelve bullets to kill the bad guys he uses
two guns.
Deadpool could have had twelve different guns
and we wouldn’t care because we had a blast
counting down those twelve bullets with him.
He can do no wrong in our eyes.
Fill in the blank, Deadpool’s roommates
name is blank blank.
We’ll reveal the answer at the end of our
video.
Tangled
Hello from your friends over at CBR, where
we look for Easter Eggs, movie blunders, crazy
facts and more on a daily basis.
Subscribe to us for fun and interesting content
daily and get ready for a Tangled Mistake
we caught.
When Flynn cuts his hand you can see a pretty
big gash right down the center.
Then why is it that in the next scene when
he comes out of the water the cut is gone?
We know it’s a cartoon and they can’t
keep a cut on there forever but maybe for
the entire day next time.
Or maybe the water is special like the water
in the Grail from Indiana Jones and the Last
Crusade, he chose wisely.
There you have it ten Mistakes In Popular
Movies That Were Caught Too Late.
Here are the answers to our trivia questions:
The Suicide Squad was originally named “TASK
FORCE X” in the comics.
Amy Poehler plays the voice of Joy in Inside
Out.
And Deadpool’s roommates name is Blind Al.
Don’t forget to subscribe to Screen Rant
for more fun videos.
Thanks for watching.